guthi rebels are not welcome here that's
the message from these protesters in the
central city tyese residents say the
local authorities put up no resistance
to the militia offensive the who thiis
now control much of the city including a
military airbase tyese is at the center
of a power struggle between Yemen's
president of drew boo Mansour Hadi and
the Shiite Houthi s the rebels have
allied themselves with supporters of
former President Ali Abdullah Saleh he
was ousted in 2012 after 30 years in
power tyese is strategically located
between the capital sanaa and aidan
president Hadi fled to Aden last month
after the who thiis seized Sanaa in a
televised address how'd he accused the
rebels of implementing a coup he
demanded that they leave sauna in Sahaba
capital and I thought for the evacuation
of all gunmen and the popular committees
they put in charge of ministries and
government institutions well my sudden
boom e3 I demand the withdrawal of all
gunmen from the yemeni capital sana and
other cities tensions flared after
suicide bombers attacked to Shiite
mosques in sanaa on Friday over a
hundred and thirty people were killed as
the security situation in Yemen
deteriorates the US has evacuated its
personnel the Houthi rebels are pushing
south as Yemen moves closer to all-out
Civil War